The point of prototypes is to
be seen and interacted with.
But who should be seeing them?
One of the most powerful concepts
in answering this question
is the idea of circles of feedback,
loosely defined there are four of them.
First, you have the product team.
As well as other people within
your company or social circle.
These people are very easy to find and
interact with but
are too close to the project to give
accurate feedback as a customer.
They're ideal for
low fidelity prototypes.
Second, you have subject matter experts.
These are people who know
something about the market in
which the product will be deployed.
But are not working on
the product with you.
They are also good for
low fidelity prototypes, and
can give you decent insight into
medium fidelity prototypes.
Third are your customers, these are
people who are in your target market,
and who you can reasonably
expect to want your app.
They give great feedback once
the prototype is of a fidelity they can
actually interact in a perfect for
medium and high fidelity prototypes.
The last circle, only applies to
some apps, but is really vital for
those apps.
These are your customer's customers.
They're really important to get
feedback from and are perfect for
the same types of prototypes
as the customers are.
Let's look at an example to
identify circles of feed back.
Pretend for a moment that I
was just making a service for
college students to do their reading and
turn in their homework assignments.
Now it's possible that I'm doing
this project on my own, but
even then it's likely that
I could find a friend or
co-worker who has gone
through the college process.
That friend is someone I
could walk to the app and
it would be in this first
circle of feedback.
The second circle would
be experts in the field.
In this case, that would be college
professors, educational theorists or
UX designers.
Third would be the college
administrators.
Does the prototype fit their needs?
As people who would actually pay for
the app, they would be the customers.
Finally, we'd want to show medium and
high fidelity prototypes to
college students themselves.
These students are out
customers' customers, and
if they don't like the app
colleges will not buy it from us.
So it's always important to test
with all four circles of feedback.
Again, this last circle only applies
to some apps, but is really vital for
those apps.